[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dès que je suis né voilà sur la plage 14
mois ballon dans les pieds une famille
de footballeurs même si ça n'a pas percé
au haut niveau mais bon voilà le
football c'est une passion et c'était
naturel pour moi de jouer au foot après
voilà j'ai fait ma petite carrière et
c'était cool y en a deux le premier
match avec le psg au parc
enfin quand on débute gamins en tant que
titi parisien c'est une fierté
et puis le deuxième c'est la victoire de
la lidia que ce fut en 2004 j'étais un
bon souvenir au stade de france
je ne sais pas intégrer un club
éventuellement dans les années qui
viennent parce que ça j'attaque ma
neuvième année aux commentaires en tant
que consultant sur bin sport j'aime
j'aime commenter les matchs mais voila
j'aimerais aussi découvrir autre chose
parce que durant la semaine j'ai du
temps de libre joue au golf c'est bien
mais bon peut-être faire autre chose